hey what's up my name is samuel lives i
had some really bad news today to be
honest i was truly good
so we had um a london crash course
booked we had to
cancel it because the hotel we went to
the whole of london went to tier three
so we had a backup venue just outside
london that then went into tier three
so then we had a backup to the backup in
southampton
a few hours ago southampton council said
sorry you can't run the event it's too
high risk so i was like oh man we are
literally people
driving to southampton if you're one of
those people i'm going to make you up to
your promise
staff going there i was absolutely
devastated
we did have a back up to the back up to
the back up to the back up
where i'm here right now now this is i'm
in i'm in slough
just outside london and this is the good
news that's the bad news by the way if
you were booked on the crash course
and you've like spent money on trains
and stuff
and you can't get it back
i'm gonna give you a voucher okay a
credit to spend on any training that
we've got because i feel awful about
that i know it's probably
all this is going to cost me a fortune
but the thing is as an entrepreneur you
need to be pushing the boat and you need
to be being creative rather than just
waiting and that's what everyone's doing
everyone's just waiting till next year
so i'm here
so here's what's happening this is the
good news the good news is
the crash course is going virtual it's
online
we're going to do it on zoom but this is
not like a normal zoom meeting this
is i've had i've had people paid big
money i've paid thousands and thousands
to have this backup ready
just in case this happened so i'm gonna
see it let's have a look
this is the back up
to the back up to the back up to the
back up
live in slough tomorrow the crash course
is happening so listen if you've never
been to the crash course
or if you live real far away or if you
couldn't make it tomorrow because of the
distance or because of covered 19
this is what's happening so i've not
seen this yet this is the very first
time i've ever been here
sounds good it feels like i feel i think
this is going to be like a real live
event
i don't know what to expect i really
don't know what to expect yes man what's
happening
so this is it oh my goodness
yes boy
so this is it this is where the property
investors crash course is going to be
held
this is going to be crazy man this is my
boy sandra's been working on this
this is back up to the back up to the
back up so we're going to sand what is
this what's this crash shows gonna be
like the first
the first ever do you know how many
years people have said to me
samuel please can you run your crash
course online can you do it live can you
do it on zoom
i've never done it this is the very
first one what's this gonna be like bro
it's gonna be sick let me tell you
something right
a lot of people have had excuses as to
why they shouldn't attend a crash course
because of
excuses like distance and all that kind
of stuff you ain't got no excuses no
more you can attend this course
from the comfort of your home or your
office this is the dude that normally
does the sound for the crash course as
well what's the crash cost like bro
insane as a property program you don't
get much better
so um oh boy we're running the program
just like a normal program
this is going to be delegates on these
screens i can speak to delegates on the
screens you're going to be big on the
screen
you know what's going to happen let me
tell you something your face is going to
be big on the screen
i'm going to be able to look you in the
eye that's what it's going to be like oh
my goodness
look at this this is about as much as
close to a live event as you can get a
physical event
so uh jeez so people are going to be
circling
i'm going to be looking you straight in
the whites of the eyes over zoom
over zoom we're going to be finding live
deals we're going to run the crash
course just as the crash course is meant
to be right
on stage people in the room so let me
tell you something
i'm really sorry we couldn't meet
physically face to face i'm really sorry
i'm really sorry if you were booked on
to southampton
you're driving down i'm really sorry get
in touch if you've lost the money over
that you can't get refunds
i will personally give you a credit
voucher okay because i don't want that
i don't want you to be out of pocket i
want you to be financially independent
so tomorrow
we're going to be meeting i think 8 a.m
registration ready for a 9 a.m start
i'm going to be going through my 12
years experience in property condensing
it into a day
here live at the property investors
crash course
virtually the first one we've ever done
so whether you're in india australia
new zealand new york germany
if you're in philadelphia i've been
there done deals if you're in scotland
ireland wales england
i hope to see you there i don't know if
we've got limited spaces or if there's
if you if i don't know how this works
what i do know is i've got the best
team in the world on the planet putting
this together
so that i can facilitate me to teach you
and give you the skills you need to know
in property
tomorrow i'm going to be live i'm just
going to be uh doing calls to estate
agents
showing you how to book deals right now
before christmas
you know what yesterday i was doing
yesterday i was in liverpool how many
deals was i doing yesterday
many many deals yesterday i was in
liverpool
christmas time everyone's winding down
these are going to be the next few days
where you're going to get a deal you're
going to bag a deal so if you want to
bag a deal before christmas
join me at the property investors crash
course tomorrow i'm going to leave a
link in the description
i think it's a one pound fee or is it
free i don't know but i'm not charging
for this program there might be a
one-pound booking thing it might be free
i'm not sure
but click the link get registered i'll
see you tomorrow
at the first ever property investors
crash course
virtually i'm members i'm mesmerized
it's going to be a mesmerizing program
i'll see that i'll leave a link in the
description
and let me tell you something man so
many people tried to stop this event the
government the councils because of
covert 19
but it is happening we are unstoppable
here at the studio i'll see you tomorrow
morning click the link get registered
it's free
i look forward to it let's bag a deal
before christmas baby